today's the day my only fans is now  available through the link in the  description below as promised the deal  is now complete and the first of three  drops of tasteful nudes is now available  for purchase the proceeds of which will  all be going to charity they'll be split  evenly between the Cincinnati Children's  Hospital in my hometown of Cincinnati  and the world food program because if  you're going to quench your thirst we  might as well try to feed some people  so  that's literally it and I know that none  of you are even here anymore you've  already clicked on that link so why am I  still talking  sorry it was late I wasn't able to  get in my office until just now  for reasons that shall remain unknown  because no one is listening to me  anymore  okay